a city is not a museum a city is a
really kind of almost a living breathing
organism Austin's the greatest city on
earth unfortunately the secret is out
our existential challenge is
affordability issues the American dream
of owning a home is harder than ever
it's especially Out Of Reach for
austinites who are facing every issue
imaginable
we travel to Texas to learn more about
their housing crisis and possible
solutions
[Music]
thank you
Austin population growth has been
growing at a very high clip for almost
150 years what changed in the 80s is
that many different types of housing
were limited or even banned to a certain
extent think of a Land Development code
as having zoning tools so you look at a
piece of land you look at the needs of a
community and then you can figure out
what you can craft to fit on this land
that fits within that zoning tool we
rewrote Our Land Development code and it
was a big down Zoning for much of Austin
Austin zoning code hasn't been updated
since 1984 when the city was less than
half its current population and housing
Supply didn't keep Pace the housing
crisis has just reached a level where
even upper middle class folks are
struggling to find housing in Austin we
saw a slow and steady appreciation of
housing prices really since the Great
Recession and then in the last couple of
years we've gone from six percent to
we're looking at 20 percent a year
appreciation in home prices so Austin
was a big benefactor of these pandemic
moves people who were newly able to work
remotely move their families and their
High salaries to Austin these low
interest rates allowed them to buy
single-family homes buy property and
that has driven up costs for a lot of
the existing Austin residents we've got
two sets of problems in a place like
Austin low-income people having a hard
time affording housing and then there's
another set of problems it's our zoning
laws are making it too expensive to
build new housing that even the middle
class could afford
so back in 2012 in an effort to get
ahead of the coming wave the city
council adopted a plan called imagine
Austin to recommend a new zoning
framework in Imagine Austin it calls for
a new Land Development code that
promotes a compact and connected City we
had this process we dubbed it code next
a small group of homeowners then filed
suit and unfortunately blocked that new
code from being passed code next is
stuck in the courts right now unclear
what's going to happen you run into the
the culture wars in imbius of as soon as
you try to do that folks that are in
these Legacy neighborhoods that are
within a few minutes of being downtown
that are there because they like the big
yards and they they like the space that
they have
part of the problem Advocates say are
restrictive zoning codes that have
existed in Austin for decades it
restricts what kind of dense housing can
be built where and it gives property
owners a lot of say in what kinds of
developments can come into their
neighborhoods one of the most
problematic aspects of Austin's zoning
regulations are the minimum lot size for
a single-family home we have a minimum
5700 square foot lot size for somebody
to build a single-family home that is
the biggest of any of the major cities
in Texas so now the housing costs have
grown or we have these single family
zoned areas we're just seeing one
million dollar homes two million dollar
homes replace those former homes that
were just torn down and so we're not
getting housing inventory but then we're
also watching that median home value of
all those neighborhoods Skyrocket
the East Cesar Chavez neighborhood is
located on the east side of Austin and
was historically one of the most diverse
communities in the city but
gentrification amid the housing crisis
has pushed old residents farther away
from downtown
in East Austin we have a zip code 78702
that area is now one of the most Posh
areas in Austin so single-family homes
that not that long ago were forty
thousand dollars are now over a million
places like East Austin which are
predominantly Black and Hispanic
neighborhoods have depressed land values
which means it's easier for developers
to come and build there versus in
communities like West Austin and Central
Austin which are more expensive to build
on and which have wider wealthier
homeowners who are able to deter And
Delay these new construction projects so
where building happens is very much
influenced by who lives in these
neighborhoods and what kind of political
power is exerted there the worst thing
that we can do for displacement and
gentrification of our working class
population especially our black and
brown population is the same thing that
we've been doing for the last 20 years
we need to build housing so all the
people that are coming because of the
Tesla Factory because of the Samsung
factory that's going to be built have
housing that they can buy and are not
competing to buy the same old little
East Austin house
foreign
homes in Austin the best and most
profitable thing that you can do is buy
an old home tear that home down and
build a huge mcmansion on that same
property I want that to change to where
that same lot is going to be redeveloped
with two homes or with three homes or
with a four-plex what's really on the
table is what are called transition
zones which are areas that are sort of
between those busy streets and then
those quiet Interiors of the
neighborhoods and that's where really a
lot of the controversy is right now how
big should those transition zones be
I'll say my personal preference is I'd
rather just raise the bar across the
whole city I think that's a simpler and
a fairer way to do it that's in fact
what the City of Minneapolis did
Citywide zoning reform has remained
elusive in the meantime Austin voters
have approved multiple Bond measures to
build affordable housing such as a 350
million dollar bond in November 2022.
honestly we probably need to add a
quarter million dollar housing Bond
every two years for the next 20 years if
we want to get a critical mass of public
housing of affordable publicly
subsidized housing that there are enough
units where we are able to house a lot
of our Working Poor and folks that
really need help you know one of the
things I'm most proud about in the time
that I've been mayor is that our city
has taken really big steps big enough to
actually bring forth real transformative
change in our city but if you don't deal
with your really big challenges then
they just get bigger
I think it's important that we look at
zoning not only as not a silver bullet
but a double-edged sword upzoning can
actually do tremendous harm to some
communities and especially the people
who are most vulnerable in the market
and upzoning only works to achieve our
housing goals if we're pairing it with
other tools and collaborations Solutions
like building on public land at deeply
affordable rates I'm a firm believer in
Community Land trusts unfortunately many
of the community-based solutions that
are truly Equitable they're not moving
at scale the most affordable units we
have are the ones we have now and it
costs us much less to protect those and
to preserve those than to build new
units it's not to say we shouldn't build
new units we need to build new
affordable housing but we're going to
have to disrupt the market as we do it
you know I think that cities that are
smaller than Austin that think they may
be on the same or a similar trajectory
over the next 10 15 20 years should be
learning going to school on us goodness
knows we did not do the things 10 and 20
years ago that we should have I would
tell other cities that they have to
prepare for the growth that is coming a
lot of times the growth and the change
is uncomfortable there is sometimes a
resentment of the newcomers but if you
don't build housing for the people that
are moving to your city you're going to
price out your current residence
[Music]
thank you